do you have any practical exercises that
writers can do for defining or
redefining their characters
i do actually so in in the book
we approach practical exercises in
a variety of different ways
so the first set of practical exercises
has to do
with walking
writers through
a discovery of their own defining
moments
and that can be that can be a pretty
emotional
thing to do to go back and and really
touch
those moments that have shaped us
in wonderful ways and terrible ways
and then we also
provide a set of exercises
that walk a writer through
discovering
their character's defining moments
and
those are
very kind of practical
here's the thing to do now set this much
time
on
you know on the timer
and
start writing and keep writing until the
timer goes off i i'm a
kind of a believer in what um
anne lamott talks about
small assignments
and in her book bird by bird
writing can be really daunting
uh because it's it's like
running a marathon
it's just
so much you can't imagine how much it is
and so
starting can be really really hard
every day when i start writing it's
still
that's the hardest thing i do
requires the most discipline and once
i've tipped over into writing
then i'm going
but it's like taking that first plunge
into the cold swimming pool in the
morning you just kind of have to give
yourself a push in the back and these
exercises are designed to say all right
blank sheet of paper pick up a pen
here's your prompt now go
i find that when writers do that
they end up writing things they didn't
mean to write
they uncover things they didn't know
were there
and
i really love it when
[Music]
we just start writing and
require ourselves to keep the pen moving
now this is a
very physical way to approach it
apart from a keyboard i think somehow
there's
some value in
actually writing with a
pen or pencil and paper
and so a prompt might be
you know think of your character
think of
how they need to grow and change
now
why have they not grown and changed in
that way yet
or
think of the way
your characters say your character's
strength or their genius
when was the first time
they realized that they had that
strength or genius
write about that for five minutes
and so you might start by writing
i'm not even sure like he knows
how good he is at the trombone
and
um
i'm not sure why he doesn't know or why
he's playing the trombone in the first
place and then you eventually if you
just keep writing
you stumble upon something that you
didn't know you were going to stumble
upon
and
um
what is it about the trombone
that is just perfect for his personality
what's happening when he's playing the
trombone what is he feeling and
that's a
really terrible example but it um
it
it shows how just doing exercises
allows you to start finding these little
starters
that will lead to bigger things
one of the chapters i think we start
with a sentence characters start at zero
meaning
as the storyteller i don't know anything
about the character when they first pop
into my mind
nor does the audience know anything
about a character
just before they step on stage
and i will only know what i know about a
character
through what i discover about them
and the audience will only know about a
character through what i reveal about
them
so i have to somehow get myself
to engage with this discovery process
and once i've
mounded up all of this raw material
then i'm ready to start writing and
doling that out
in a strategic way
as i tell the story
these exercises are designed to give
writers and actors and directors
practice
thinking about and working with
characters in this way so that all of us
can make the discoveries uh that are
going to make for rich and lifelike
characters who can transform before our
eyes
you know when you mentioned anne
lamott's bird by bird i believe the
title
if i remember correctly is based on a
conversation she had with a grandfather
or uncle
where you just take it a little bit of a
time bird by bird yes i think she had to
write a report about
birds and she was looking out the window
maybe at a flock of birds and she was
just overwhelmed how am i going to do
this
i think her dad was a professional
writer or professor and he said well ann
just take it bird by bird
and i think that's just some of the best
advice
for any writer
how can an actor use defining moments to
build their character
kathy and i interviewed
several actors
as we were writing this book because we
really wanted to understand
how
how these ideas could be useful to
actors
we talked to
two-time emmy winner tony hale
and talked to him about this and he said
you know
um
i have found that when i will dig into
my own
moments that have shaped me and defined
me
the performance changes in a way that is
appreciable he had just come from
recording
a voice
for an animated project
and he said
and i did that i tapped into something
that was really real and deep for me
and you could just tell the energy in
the booth changed when i did that
and he said i don't know why i don't do
that all the time
i suppose
it's costly emotionally to do that
but
he absolutely recognized that
by
thinking about
the single character that he's embodying
and portraying
seeking to understand what are the
moments that really have shaped and
define this character
how do those moments connect with my own
life experience
he's able to infuse
greater depth and complexity
into
those characters
and he said when he auditions
he
seeks to bring
himself in that way
to the role
and he says i you know i may not
when i audition for that role may not be
the tallest or the this or that
that they're looking for
but i can guarantee
that i will have delivered an audition
that nobody else delivered
because they can't they don't have
access
to his inner life only he does
that is the unique
gold that he can mine and bring forward
in auditions and performances and
i think any actor
uh can benefit from that
and
and
what i think is so useful for me as a
writer and for actors is that
we're talking about a limited number of
things that we need to discover about
the character
we don't have to know everything about
every year of their lives we just need
to locate those moments that have most
shaped them and
it gives us this deep understanding
that
gives all of us access in an empathetic
way to the humanity of that character
but possibly the actor could have
a history in their back pocket and it
might lend to
a heaviness here a relief here
yeah exactly and and that's that's for
me as a as a writer a really exciting
thing i'm collaborating with an actor
to create this character i do my part
first
and then i pass the baton to the actor
and the director
and
they bring their resources which are
different from my resources
and when it all works
the way we dream it will work
then you get this really rich character
who does things that the writer never
even imagined
and the actor has got to hope that the
writer
put
on the page
enough
for them to work with and then they can
pick up that baton and carry it further